sandrine charlie je crois et est venue
avec vous ce soir on a tous dans cette
vidéo
j'ai une petite surprise pour charlie
donc est ce que il est lâche qui veut
bien rentrés sur le plateau charlie
j'espère que ça lui fait plaisir mais
nos fans
on en est là c'est pas trop tard elle
est par l'émission bah ouais je préfère
profiter des émissions plutôt est
magnifique en tout cas bon je suis très
content de te voir ce soir est content
d'être en week end avec maman oui tu vas
rester à paris ce week-end c'est pas
tout en visite à paris
tout vice bloquer un partout je le dis
parce que j'ai une petite j'aime bien de
surprises pour toi qui tu aimes bien
comme chanteur soprano damien soprano je
crois qu'il ya fait une petite un petit
truc revient ça lui sert ni salut
charlie day c'est son prénom j'espère
que ça va voilà ta vie d'où elle m'a
beaucoup touché je voulais juste te
faire un petit coucou d'envoyer plein
plein plein plein plein plein de bisous
te dire que tu es magnifique
j'ai grandi à l'intérieur et que
j'espère qu'on se verra bientôt en tout
cas ce qu'ont fait des bises à toi et à
ta maman et à tout le monde ciao charnue
ont fait plaisir aux bains
le nouveau grand habit toutefois ces
housses à côté de marseille sa maman c
ou dans le nord non mais non mais parce
qu'on m'a dit qu'il voulait il voulait
il a mené le foot
oui tête c'est quoi ton équipe préférée
harris temp à marseille même un petit
peu marseille j'avais l'éviter au
vélodrome comme il aimait soprano puis
maintenant est-ce qu alors qu'ils
viennent d'en avoir su reprendre une
série originale qu'est ce que tu veux
aller un jour au parc des princes avec
moi oui c'est vrai tu aimerais voir quel
match psg quoi tu veux qu'on aille voir
voilà dans vos tu veux que je te mènera
m'as tu as dans l'est dans les trois
semaines
carette a envie de venir avec moi bon
c'est bien est envie d'aller au
vélodrome aussi ce qu'on est une petite
surprise pour toi tu vas aller à paris
c'est tu vas aller au parc des princes
et tu vas aller au vélodrome regarde au
soir charlie bauer arthur je suis jérôme
renard de l'association jaune dans la
même équipe mais simple message pour
vous dire que nous vous invitons avec
mon ami julien à venir voir un match de
l'olympique de marseille
ici au stade vélodrome le match de votre
choix dites-nous lequel et vous êtes
nous a évité une bise à votre famille
il ne vise aussi à cyril hanouna
l'association précitée
ils font des choses incroyables
en tout cas moi tu sais que je suis là
c'est tellement drôle problème no 6 en
l'état on t'aime petit je t'aime fort
[Applaudissements]
il est beau il sont jaloux il est
tellement beau ah c'est ça c'est ça le
problème
bref chez moi j'étais moche est passé
pro c'est vrai c'est ça te fait un gros
bisou on va au parc des princes en
bientôt tu me dis que ça va mieux tu me
fait sourire
[Applaudissements]
valero moment je n'ai pas vraiment de
quoi de rester avec moi bah tu as bien
raison obama apparemment ça y est on va
rester ensemble un ta [ __ ] dans le dos
rond puces et a vu que j'étais pas bon
géographie